many don't know that the man named
mendoza was once a masked wrestler
himself
i was the pride and joy of my hometown
of canal espacio
i faced off and unmasked 10 000 warriors
in single combat in the ring with every
battle my powers grew and i could soon
eliminate opponents by simply staring
them dead in the eye picturing their
worst memory and projecting it into
their subconscious like a psychic
flashbang that would reduce grown men to
weeping masses of failure
i wore the belt with pride after
decimating hundreds
but one day i hung it all up because i
knew
no one masked wrestler should have the
power to show others the void within
their own minds
the void of white emptiness where the
purest form of evil lurks
man himself
i have seen what lies within
the gutter space
the only pop culture news show where the
host is foaming at the mouth eager to
tear into your jugular at a moment's
notice
venom 3 is being made that's good news i
like venom venom's fun i hope the
xenophage is in it
turn into inanimate objects you i like
that guy i hope he's wanting the bad guy
if you were morbidly curious about
morbius and discovered it was just more
bs then you'll know why it was a
critical and financial failure but the
film industry's takeaway lesson from
that is not that casting jared leto is a
lame [ __ ] see-less spider-man villain in
a movie without spider-man isn't a
formula for success
but that vampires aren't cool anymore i
guess so a bunch of upcoming movies
about dracula and nosferatu have been
canceled and has sony learned their
lesson why yes instead of c-list super
villains they're going for z
stick around for the rest of the video
but first a word from our sponsor
special thanks to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video get mouth-watering
seasonal recipes and fresh pre-measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
with hellofresh america's number one
meal kit hellofresh makes cooking at
home fun easy and affordable no matter
what's going on in the world everyone's
gotta eat that's why hello fresh is here
to make eating better and easier no
grocery stores no stressful meal
planning just everything you need to
prepare wholesome delicious meals all
delivered to your door with 50 weekly
options including a rotating selection
of items at hella fresh market there are
plenty of delicious dishes to choose
from no matter the occasion hellofresh
has options forever on including family
friendly fit and wholesome and quick and
easy meals so there's something to
please even the pickiest eater at your
table even if that's you
and hella fresh recipes feature produce
sourced directly from u.s farmers and
picked at peak ripeness
it goes from the farm to your front door
in under a week which means their spring
menu features the season's fresh flavors
my mom got a subscription to hella fresh
a few years ago and i ended up eating
all of the meals with her and a lot of
the recipes were so nice we began
cooking them ourselves really frequently
so hellofresh introduced me to some of
my new favorite meals and they're really
affordable and a lot healthier than
frequent trips to grab fast food
use my link or go to hellofresh.com and
use the code
pogzillamay16 for up to 16 free meals
plus three surprise gifts across six
hello fresh boxes plus free shipping
once you click my description will live
update to count the purchases
now back to the video next up on sony's
run of out of the park ideas el muerto
the movie
played by rapper bad bunny who has
basically no real acting credits to his
name so you know he's going to be a
great leading man amorto is a one-off
antagonist from the friendly
neighborhood spider-man side series from
2006 by peter david amuerto exists in
exactly two issues where he's a luchador
that must protect his life from another
luchador with magic powers named
eldorado by unmasking another champion
in combat so he challenges spider-man to
battle for charity with jonah jameson's
help because he's always being a little
rascal muerto's powers include i don't
know nothing it's not really defined
he's kind of just a normal guy
i think it's
said that he's stronger than average in
fact in this issue flash thompson
describes him as quote some mexican
wrestler no one's ever heard of
yes give that guy a movie spider-man
beats up el dorado for him so he's off
the hook and he's never seen or heard
from again this is apparently enough
material for a multi-million dollar
theatrically released movie this is so
bottom of the barrel it's actually worse
than any joke suggestion we've made over
the years after sony got a bug up their
ass about obscure nobodies like jackpot
and shameless spawn rip off nightwatch
like at least those [ __ ] characters
showed up more than two issues jackpot
had a three issue miniseries and a bunch
of appearances in spiderman nightwatch
had 12 solo issues and a couple
appearances here and there that's like
really minimal but it's something if
this is the caliber of characters we're
pulling from then we need to up the ante
with these jokes hey sony how about a
movie about fusion the twin terror it's
about a couple of brothers with dwarfism
that form into one average size glowing
mutant man with two heads you can have
peter dinklage play both roles he's a
big name right
i bet he's got more star power than bad
bunny oh [ __ ] what about a movie about
freak
or freak with a ph then you can have a
crossover movie called freak vs freak
[ __ ] it i might be giving them ideas
what a massive joke i would like to
believe that this is just a comedic
publicity stunt not a real decision
that's this unfathomably inept like when
they kept doing that joke thing in 2012
where high moon studios announced they
were making a game based on the hit
monkey comic and then deadpool showed up
at the panel and hijacked it to force
them at gunpoint to make a deadpool game
instead i may not have liked the game
itself that much but that was clever
marketing if that's the ploy then this
is a sort of funny way to get eyes on a
mystery project but if this is unironic
then like
dozens of high-level people need to be
fired you want some legitimate ideas
like i'm not joking here spider-man 2099
is like really easy mayday parker spider
girl and her parents are toby and
kirsten that way you can bring them back
superior foes of spider-man is like a
funny buddy comedy heist movie would be
cool
so much that you could do that's not el
muerto
meanwhile in another universe where
movies are competently made spider-man
across the spider-verse has been delayed
by several months but they did show some
footage of miles gwen miguel and a
pregnant jessica drew fighting what
might be a noir version of vulture who's
a scary cannibal who eats people it
sucks that we have to wait yet another
year for it to finally drop but it's a
big project and is apparently the
biggest crew of an animated movie ever
with over a thousand animators all of
whom i'm sure will be properly credited
and fairly compensated for their work
right i'm sorry if i sound sarcastic and
bitter i'm still hung up on el morto
like craven i get he has a lot of lore
and story lines and a bunch of adjacent
characters
madame webb is its own thing that could
introduce all the magic elements of
spider-man mythos so that's like
justifiable on some level even morbius i
guess because people at least recognize
him to some extent from the cartoons and
games
but
[ __ ] el muerta marvel released a
trailer for thor love and thunder which
will be adapting the jason aaron run of
thor where jane foster get the canker
thor many of you may be asking isn't it
kinda weird to call her thor now because
that's not like a title or persona it's
the guy's name
and yes you're right but also there's a
bunch of [ __ ] guys called thor and
they aren't this guy either and it's a
dumb comic book movie for 14 year olds i
don't care anymore it's not an
adaptation of actual norse mythology and
i'm pretty sure the nords never had any
stories in their religion about loki
serving a purple space alien to invade
the city of new york so getting pissy
about it now is just arbitrary they did
however have stories of him turning into
a female horse at giving birth to an
eight-legged horse monster named slippy
whatever you can be thor if you want no
one's stopping you this is all stupid
with biceps like that i wouldn't even
want to try from any guy in hollywood
trailer has a lot of nice color cool art
design interesting set pieces and some
really shockingly accurate comic imagery
like so accurate it looks like they
traced the panel to make this shot
identical to sad rubik's art in the
comic and i'm sure he will be properly
credited and compensated for his work
you know since he
basically storyboarded this shot for you
maybe they'll even spell his name right
because somehow movies sometimes
struggle with that i like that thor has
his classic costume in one shot in a
context other than to actively mock this
look marvel's been doing better about
that lately i'll give them props it used
to be this recurring gag of pointing at
a comic accurate costume and going ha ha
this is stupid but now they're doing it
a little more respectfully and i
honestly appreciate that
taika watiti is one of the better
directors doing marvel stuff lately and
has a really solid body of work and
decent comedy chops
if his funnier take on thor isn't for
you that's totally understandable but
i'm willing to give it a chance i didn't
really love thor ragnarok myself but i
enjoyed some of the character
development here and there and you know
it had some standout moments
i imagine this will be kind of the same
deal so i don't know if i'm gonna like
it but we'll see the doctor strange
trailer came out ages ago so i feel like
it would be weird to go over now
but here are a few thoughts about it
based on the marketing before it comes
out this week i hope mr fantastic is in
there because that would be funny but
i'm also worried from the rumors that
they'll go a little overboard and cram
in too many references inside characters
to the point that it'll get overstuffed
i got faith in good old sam though he
directed evil dead and that movie's
pretty cool
in other news there's a new kingdom
hearts game and people are a little
weirded out by the photorealistic art
style after all the previous games had
this spiky anime man in his clown shoes
maybe this one will have marvel and star
wars stuff now since projects like this
are a perfect place for companies to
just go look at all the rights i bought
like ready player one or space jam 2 we
could get scrooge mcduck and deadpool
teaming up to defeat darth vader oh
disney
the cassian andor show was originally
slated to last five seasons i guess but
then they decided to chill out and do
maybe three instead and uh
yeah i i honestly have no idea how
anyone could look at that character and
go yeah that guy's worth watching for
around 2015 minutes of content but yeah
good for diego luna for getting that
paycheck either way on the dc front
discovery and warner brothers have
merged and the first order of business
is to revamp their current plans for
movies this includes finding a kevin
feige-like producer to wrangle these
together instead them all being
like kind of director driven but also
kind of not because the studio kept
meddling they also want to revitalize
characters like superman and keep doing
projects like batman and joker this
confuses me because getting a kevin
feige guy
means making a shared universe more
coherent right but batman and joker are
like successful and interesting because
they're not part of a shared universe so
i think some further clarification on
that could be helpful i want to be
optimistic i i mean uh
i'm excited for batman too that would be
cool a new superman movie could be
really cool
he's not a hard character to get right
everyone's really overthinking it he's
just a really chill dude and it's ironic
that he's so gentle and kind considering
he's so insanely powerful if you can
wrap your head around one punch man or
goku from dragon ball this is not a
difficult concept
he's the kind of guy that would help you
move if you asked him to because he's
got a dope pickup truck sometimes he
gets a little overwhelmed when everyone
asks him to help them move on the same
weekend you know i don't know what the
hell their plan is for aquaman 2 and the
flash though because uh i mean like you
know
maybe just digitally replace barry and
miro with christopher plummer and tig
notaro respectively movie magic the rock
is producing a movie based on the game
it takes two on amazon prime which is
really far from my guess that he was
involved with mortal kombat
is this the biggest most badass game he
was referring to
that would actually be hilarious
there's a new ghostbusters movie that's
a sequel to the new ghostbusters movie
but it's unrelated to the new
ghostbusters movie that everyone hated
that's all the news i find interesting
enough to talk about it's a dry spell
but i don't want people to forget this
series exists so i just felt like kind
of taking a minute to talk with you all
again my last video was crazy and i've
never gotten that opportunity for
something like that or really any of the
amazing collabs we've done on the
channel over the last year and a half
without your continued support
so thank you guys for making my dreams
come true helping us with all of our
ambitious wacky ideas through the
patreon or keeping the views up on our
bigger projects or just being active in
the community in general thanks guys i
love you lots be on the lookout for all
the other crazy collabs we'll be doing
this year because we're still going
post in the comments your favorite
spider-man villain that only appeared in
one issue that you'd love to see get a
whole movie trilogy because that's where
we're headed
until next time buckaroos
[Music]
you